bien sûr depuis cinq ans la ville de new
york a pansé ses plaies mais le quartier
du world trade center est toujours très
marquée par les attentats il y a bien
sûr ce vide béant au milieu des tours
mais surtout le déficit économique les
entreprises ont beaucoup de mal à
reprendre leurs activités à l'exception
du secteur touristique
dopé par la venue de milliers de
personnes qui veulent absolument voir le
site des attentats reportage de nos
correspondants à l'âme chalon et aaron
diamant de l'ancien world trade center
il ne reste que la gare du rer détruites
le 11-septembre mais réhabilitée et
remise en service en un temps record
elle est essentielle à la vie de new
york et drainent vers le quartier des
dizaines de milliers de personnes par
jour compris blanc ainsi à sa
résurrection enfin son début de
résurrection les choses ne seront plus
jamais comme avant
cela fait 25 ans que je travaille dans
le quartier mais les cinq dernières
années n'ont rien à voir
un bâtiment a été reconstruit la tour
numéro 7 la noire inauguré l'an dernier
pour le reste c'est le trou toujours le
tronc de nombreux commerces qui porte
encore les stigmates du 11 septembre
sont fermés les propriétaires ont
déménagé d'autres font faillite et ceux
qui restent se plaignent ce qui est
différent à c'est tout simplement qu'il
n'ya plus le world trade center
avec ses dizaines de milliers de clients
potentiels c'est ça la différence au
début on a perdu 75% et maintenant c'est
la moitié il ya tellement de sociétés
qui ont mis la clé sous la porte ou
déménager il n'y a pas assez de clients
pour faire de l'argent
le centre nerveux de ce bout méridionale
de new york
c'est toujours wall street la bourse et
ses courtiers pressés et stressés
les gens font encore peur mais c'est
business as usual
les affaires sont les affaires une
nouvelle activité
paradoxal fait revivre le quartier le
tourisme grande 0 est devenu le site le
plus visité de new york
les hôteliers du secteur qui ont connu
trois années noires après les attentats
ne se plaignent plus la semaine
prochaine si vous cherchez une champagne
york c'est impossible
et maintenant je vois très bien que
c'est la reprise des affaires à new york
et même pour l'hôtellerie et c'est une
connaissance des affaires figurent enfin
il ya un secteur d'activité qui a
profité bien involontairement du drame
les lieux de culte ici l'église saint
paul à deux pas de ground zero couverte
d'ex voto elle ne désemplit pas
mais il est vrai qu ici on ne vend rien
qu'un peu de réconfort